Oh Gomez my name Robert I'll come back
to the mannequin Factory hey whoa thank
you hey I got your hand even though I
did that I'm most grateful for it
thank you I don't even know you can do
that what's up Manny so this is actually
Bart's mannequin I don't trust you that
huh look you had birds from me Greg Bird
Greg I don't know what I just said but
that's a good man welcome back to condom
I'll take your an - sir thank you very
much [ __ ] whoa someone up there
Wow funky priests like a dog
lock him down well
what is that [ __ ] whoa dude oh I got
you [ __ ] hahaha uh I got damnit this
whoa leave I tasty bro lame lame note
fine I'll just go over here then see if
I care
I don't see how much I care I got a
mannequin arm why would I care
stop grabbing you whose day well do I
have to kill you I have to do it
slap bad ah ah ow [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
that's right my mannequin arms you don't
[ __ ] with my mannequin I don't want that
[ __ ] it's going here look you made him
all red and [ __ ] disappointment bring it
all up ya see I'm ready
I got Manny with me manage my brows
let's go now Wow
you totally ma a damn Indy point you
suck man let's check over here
well it's creepy with the ice whoa dude
so many [ __ ] people what are they
doing here
makes no sense whatever I don't care
you got a Taser picture anyone following
me
hey don't you don't you - shoot huh huh
tag read
come on now let's look at bran what's
going on there uh [ __ ] cook whoa what
that Santa Santa what are you going
Santa Santa please why did you give me
presents so so that is what you get for
not giving me presents
[ __ ] you Santa [ __ ] you Santa what the
[ __ ] are you going do don't you run away
from me
William like that's twice of them don't
make you kill me no [ __ ] you [ __ ] is
going on oh [ __ ] you
Santa Claus [ __ ] I blocked oh it's a
good time that's right close the rash
all right no [ __ ] know about it the
[ __ ] man Santa why did he do it
I need help now Santa I need it bad it's
any help here
I killed you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you Santa
Thank You Santa I'm pissed now Santa
nice butt
whoa don't walk away from me son whoa
Wow big slap blockage sticks up okay if
your face was in your deck die would it
what [ __ ] mannequins man I trust any
one of you well I kill you with your
friends that's right
[ __ ] trust dear oh and I'll
investigate them alright and trust this
[ __ ]
I guess this I gotta miss the game
alright time to take a photo there we go
what does that mean I don't know it's
[ __ ] sander glass ow dude I have to
investigate again I like that
I don't like it miss oh there it is
let's take a photo that
I get enough huh buddy you're doing hair
lady I'm talking on the phone oh oh
she's gonna get tased mani before I get
my hair girl and the hell did she come
from
mr. shet what the hell damn it I'm what
I might uncommon MA
lady I would call I don't have to kill
you you know just kidding ha ha ha ha
[ __ ] sorry
well I don't trust any one of you
don't scare me [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
that's right what I'm not dead I'm alive
oh god dad sleepy
bring it that's Karen sound up you yeah
you [ __ ] up I got a laser gun Santa
don't make me use it Santa I swear to
God don't make me use it there's some
glowy [ __ ] over here sign that I'm gonna
investigate it it's just a [ __ ] light
I'm stupid
maybe there's a trail or something
Santa not cool you're gonna hit me from
there
pitch what do something come on
are you going where you going [ __ ] did
you get that from blockage you can't
even hit the P I know s that's right
pick it to power that's right
you which one do you want which one you
want I let you choose no matter to that
watch ha
god damn easily god damn I don't like
this
what am I supposed to oh there it is
alright there's the trail
I think I'm following it in the wrong
direction though there we go
why does it
following the trail it keeps going to
the elevator so now I can move I know
you got a lot of creeper this
got myself watching I guess cool cool
I'm not scared so what do I do it's
light she well what's the point of it
I prefer Manny I mean he's pretty cool
about things
oh man I'm freaking the hell out of me
Santa don't do it don't do it man
what where do you come from [ __ ] you got
back up and [ __ ] seriously I admire your
beard man but you have to die are you
scared now you run you run I'll do with
this one that's right whoa why I said it
twice
blockage I don't push him blockage
fletchie fletchie [ __ ] [ __ ] you
don't [ __ ] with me okay we're good her
than good we are really great but I wish
I know where I was going
it would help the situation okay here we
go
stop hammer time Hey okay now there's
sledge hammer it stop
cool I'll take that one thank you very
much
send him on down here hey hey hey
yeah no no no no don't shoot me don't
shoot me don't you
I'm allergic to bullets [ __ ] yes thank
you
hey bring it see my stroke strafing
skills you don't know what to do about
it
baba oh hey like your face even better
not okay of course it's out of bullets
got them I see yeah
it's [ __ ] obvious you're even looking
at it dude
how do you do that video sorry but you
have to die now
whoa don't block Hey go not cool man
[ __ ] I hate them what
[ __ ] you by Christmas tree into it don't
do it man
it's not gonna be worth it what am i
doing why did he take that up what the
hell I did not click dad why it's like
oh I gotta investigate these face yeah
good idea man I'll see you in a couple
seconds cuz god damn it it's gonna be a
lot of people here hey lady
you're not going hate when I hate one of
your tactics it on me and [ __ ] stop that
nonsense
hey you know I have a shotgun right he
doesn't even care hey you see this you
see this isn't you dying the brass don't
shoot don't try to sneak up on me you
crazy [ __ ]
oh one shot him Undead don't [ __ ] with
me girl
oh oh ho she wants to tango I
she doesn't even know Fox tried yet god
dammit that's how I roll alright come on
black boot slapping I quicksave don't
worry I got this what
okay headshot let's go for the head go
for the head oh he's like where's my gun
Oh oh-ho you lost your face okay hello
gross he distracted me with this
disgustingness one last try last try
that's right that's right that's right
Oh successful okay I am officially
screwed hey hey hey it's Dumbledore how
you doing man
I looked everywhere for you now that
Harry Potter in my collection
why doesn't these presents give you
anything dad make me angry so I I I can
- oh no he has a shotgun
I should quick say where'd he go
nice sneaky [ __ ] go Gotti's both of
them thank you
ma'am they do a lot of very much
pika power peak a slap speak a blockage
whoa nice shot [ __ ] [ __ ] you
please have ammo please have them all
how much Oh three that's not bad
I like you now thank you Karen sir where
the [ __ ] is she [ __ ] man are you [ __ ]
man again whoa whoa [ __ ] you listen okay
stop stop right now not not not not okay
not okay not okay okay no no no now I
don't what are you
what jumped down oh you bet it sorry
you're not a [ __ ] stupid [ __ ] I
can't do [ __ ] bro what the [ __ ] is good
no no no no we're not doing this anymore
not I don't play games man don't no no
it's over
it's all right Laser laser follow as I'm
following following thank you enjoy
gotta come rooted in I'll see you next
episode stay awesome bros I'm done here
jump oh oh
well
somebody out there
[ __ ] this [ __ ]
[Music]